Hai
you ministers meeting in the general
affairs Council on December sixteen will
your commitment to the US enlargement of the
process of
khai very economic governance And public
administration for the upcoming
opposite 7 broad crusher in those jeans
stabilization Association process is no
concern with Turkey Serbia Montenegro
albaini bosnia-  herzegovina
following
Dialogue with the most extreme in the key
of
temporary suspension of
the Wireless network brand for next year
and take note of reflections on how to
improve the functioning of the You might
think only Two days ahead of the
European Council on I'm December
ministers will examine the draft
conclusions of The Summit Yuli the
suitcase investment in your own the
situation in yuk Rain amongst other
issues the mission represented in
webbrowser fourtwnty vetsin website What
more can be turned you let the hell
brush member States could finally
benitez will discuss the  US route
Hi Ho